I don't know when you're gonna call us
or when I sleep when I'm not holding no
it's not unreasonable at all
excuse me take it the boss lady's on the
warpath this morning I really think I
could help this company you just gave me
a chance just concentrate on being my
assistant or you always mean I got big
and I got rich so now we're gonna check
me boo I wish you were my age and I
check you well I wish you were little I
told you watch it this you want to read
growing and look up
white people cuz but people don't have
the time
Child Protective Services enrolled this
child in school or somebody is going to
jail somebody shortened everyone else
you're a child so you have to start
acting like it get back to work
whose child is this I need you to cover
for me in the office
I should really dress the part your body
convinced my clothes miss Pilates that
body looks like Baby Gap Gymboree ass
gospel gosh to be a spy damn girl lookin
like cookie from Empire
there's your teacher I could tell that
you are a special young lady effective
really I feel like I get you - so you
feeling what I'm feeling no I'm not
feeling that at all don't don't look at
me like that just look look look the
other way look through it look the look
up there
what is going on I'm April available
think you're the boss of me say one more
thing I dare you you're too fast for
that skirt
okay see I've been looking at you like a
little girl but you a grown-ass woman we
have a BMW situation black mama whooping
your kids mom you're my mama
[Music]